un escándalo de filtración de documentos
secretos principalmente sobre la guerra
en Ucrania que había pasado
desapercibida hasta la revelación del
periódico estadounidense de New York
Times el 7 de abril ahora la filtración
sacude a más aliados de Estados Unidos y
ha obligado a que el departamento de
Justicia inicie una investigación y que
el Secretario de Defensa loyd Austin se
pronuncie
me informaron por primera vez sobre los
informes de divulgación no autorizada de
material confidencial y clasificado en
la mañana del 6 de abril hemos remitido
el asunto al departamento de Justicia
que ha abierto una investigación penal
les diré que nos tomamos esto muy en
serio y continuaremos investigando y
removiendo cada piedra hasta que
encontremos la fuente de esto y su
alcance
decenas de fotos de los documentos
algunos marcados como Ultra secretos han
estado circulando en redes sociales y
servicios de mensajería como discord
Twitter y Telegram antes de ser
descubiertos por el gobierno
estadounidense los documentos incluyen
evaluaciones del pentágono según las
cuales Ucrania podría quedarse sin
municiones en cuestión de semanas estos
documentos también revelan información
sobre otros aliados como Israel Turquía
Australia y Corea del Sur algunos
sugiriendo que Estados Unidos estaba
espiando las conversaciones internas en
seúl dado que Corea del Sur y Estados
Unidos son aliados en materia de
inteligencia ahora llevamos a cabo
juntos actividades de inteligencia sobre
cuestiones importantes se espera que
este incidente sirva para que ambas
partes sigan reforzando la confianza
mutua pero los expertos en inteligencia
afirman que espiar a otros países
incluidos los aliados es una práctica
bastante habitual en la política
internacional y nada que esos países no
sepan ya el pentágono afirma que ha
tomado medidas para reducir el número de
personas que tienen acceso al material
clasificado